last night another black man was
murdered lynched again by the police
again this morning my folks said I
should try to unplug from the news cycle
again this morning I accepted I can't
unplug when it's mine dying again last
night they said the murder was justified
because some sort of past crime again
this morning proved that was a lie again
last night they said wait for the facts
trust a justice system again this
morning no charges were brought to that
cop again last night we tried peaceful
tactics t-shirts bent knees silent
demonstrations again this morning they
dismissed us and mocked us again last
night
the language of the unheard was spoken
at the top of their lungs in the form of
burning buildings again this morning
they said we were thugs again they said
follow the law again we said you first
again last night
they said violence undermined our cause
again this morning we said then why do
you keep driving tanks into our
neighborhoods again this morning I'm
busy or in nauseous fearful frustrated
angry detached annoyed pissed II
exhausted worried overwhelmed again last
night a black man got lynched again by
the police again last night again this
morning again here we go